probiotics in the present talk
anyway
coming specifically to the Women's
Health
microbes are special attachment with
women because
they are a part of the vaginal cavity
they have a role to play in first
sitting of the child with microbes
and they are important in deciding the
health and many other characters to a
child and mother both so women's
microphora has additional significant
role to play because it decides the
generations coming Generations too and
hence the microbiome of
females especially vaginal tract has
become more more important
so we want to know that what probiotic
can do for women
everybody wants to be happy healthy and
especially for the women they want to be
beautiful
many more things will be there
so in these areas of the Health
Nutrition and cosmetics
how the probiotic can play a role that
is the focus of today's talk and I will
share some of the work carried out with
other people as well as some of the
examples of workout where my two of my
students for their were related to
another for cosmetic applications
a lot of work
has been done on probiotics and it is
continuing
since the
concept of probiotics was first
put forth
or the world came to know about the
beneficial microbes through the
publication of a book called as
prolongation of life
1907 by Ali mechanical
and then many people started working on
beneficial role of microphora in human
health
and at the moment we have ample evidence
that probiotics have
role to play nearly in the
gastrointestinal tract and now it is
extended to human brain and other
bodies of the
other organisms in one body so rule in
relieving diarrhea or
keeping the your GI tract healthy or
even a modulation or anti-carcinogenic
anti diabetic post
especially when you take base products
lactose intolerance it is very important
but apart from the generic role it has a
specific role to play uh in the women's
health
digestive disorders
especially screen care cosmetics so here
we'll touch up a little bit on skin
microbiome too
uh
and then it has a role to play
especially through God and through other
uh organs in immunity they moved
especially connecting the gut brain axis
and most typically is vaginal health and
urinary
infections and control of that and